l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono la vj allo ragazzi il video
di oggi è diversissimo da ogni cosa
praticamente sono venuti qua i miei
amici a casa mia qui in questo luogo
abbiamo giocato tutti e tre insieme
nella stessa stanza quindi io su questo
computer ei miei due amici sui due
computer di fianco e ho registrato
questa cosa anche se ci ho messo una
vita in mezza montarla lo registra è una
roba che non ha senso ci vedrete dei
pezzi di gameplay che non hanno senso di
esistere però dovevo provare a fare una
volta questa cosa della mia vita quindi
l'ho fatta e sti cazzi primo giallo
rocket league
ok buona visione e gli altri ti ragazzi
benvenuti ha visto video sarò farisei e
oggi è sabato sera non seriamente oggi e
sabato sera e tre ragazzi cosa fanno un
sabato sera a bando con gli amici fuori
a socializzare no giocano rocket league
quando perdiamo solo clic che siamo
ognuno a casa nostra ci incazziamo l'uno
bollato adesso possiamo tirarci pugni
sui denti se perdiamo perché siamo
vicini a una domanda che non riguarda il
video lì c'è la mattina di birra e liceo
e telecamere si vede tutto bene potresti
toglierla grazie ai tutti i cazzotti ma
[ __ ]
non è vero non è vero
peculato vai vai vai ancora si è vantata
gts3 empi e credo sia un detto bene a te
l'ho detto io pure 40 ragazze o donne
che questi sono dati a casa si sono
arresi tirava avanti tele in cui vado un
po poco fuori
era già dentro io allora tu non capisci
la fisica
tu non capisci le cose io stavo portando
la palla dentro che cazzo arrivi così in
casa mia la palla e finisce così 41 lega
piccola piscina
basta girare il video che cantano in
mezzo che è esploso io capisco niente
bravo bravo segna segna segna 19 turno
non ci arriva ma cosa te coach e questo
è tutto a briaco basta bere la birra nei
video out riardo guarda male
intanto a trovare cioè aggravata non è
niente che ha persa che non ce la
facciamo più
e tra chi e dove tre giorni [ __ ]
e che gol bravissimo cosa facciamo
basta guardarmi vietti soggezioni sono
una cosa una timida basta avere a matri
guida ubriachi dai segnati ce l'avete li
porti allontana porca [ __ ]
la cazzano tutti 12 guarda guarda guarda
guarda ventura molto altro e mori ha
visto il tiro bello ha detto va bene due
entrare questa cosa si tratti ma danni
spaccagli bravo bravo che vinciamo si è
che i ragazzi questa è la più media era
più o meno rocket league
passiamo ad h 10 nomi li metterei con
cap 11 13
la parola credici sulla forza vieni che
giochiamo dai che deve andare sud sud
est
oddio che cazzo succede visto molti non
lo so è una casetta sotto l'albero
eccoci tutti forti arriviamo facciamo i
culi vinciamola questa partita dai come
igienica risparmio di torino dopo aver
trovato tutti e tutti i fucili tutte le
armi quindi stavamo messi benissimo ho
trovato un quad e per andare più veloce
e luca è salito sul mio quad ed è andata
a finire
più o meno così madonna che salvo quando
a nome mio tg non mi far domande non so
come ho fatto a morire c'era una collina
ma non pensavo mai di saltare anche un
albero ho capito che non è solo io
contro un albero e quindi ragazzi questo
era un video e credono fatti di vito
strani ma questo proprio e tanto strano
lasciate un mi piace anche sono aveva
senso di esistere
va bene così i ragazzi si vede è
piaciuto al momento mi piace anche a
pacelli facebook e coniglio tornare
iscrizioni essere cities capisci vediamo
proseguito ai ragazzi che cosa avete
appena visto dio mio